as the uk looks to the clean energy of
the future the realities of the present
are about to catch up with power
companies unprotected against the shock
of a spike in global gas prices
among them bulb whose one and a half
million customers face uncertainty
i'm hearing today that these price
changes are going to keep rising is a
little bit of a worry i don't think that
utility companies will find themselves
in this position it comes along with
increasing petrol prices and i guess
food prices as well because stock seems
to be going down on the shelves
and electricity prices
that
you know it's a worry gas prices
customers of failing companies will
automatically move to other providers
british gas has taken on 350 000 this
week but with up to one in four
households signed to suppliers that
could face collapse government-backed
loans could be used to cover the cost of
millions of customers moving firstly mr
speaker
i must stress
that protecting consumers
is our number one our primary focus
there is absolutely no question mr
speaker of the lights going out or
people being unable to heat their homes
soaring prices have exposed new entrants
that promise cheap deals they can no
longer afford to deliver because they
haven't hedged or insured their supplies
on the wholesale markets i don't feel
green will make it through the winter i
don't think there'll be many suppliers
that do we're up to 12 today on gas
prices already as these continue to rise
and this price keep going it will put
pressure across the whole marketplace
the energy price cap set by regulator
off-gem means providers can't increase
bills to match real-world prices that
could stay high all winter a signs say
some of a broken market i've never
thought the price cap was a good idea
too much interference in the market in
that respect in terms of pricing and not
enough interference in the market in
terms of the business plans of the new
entrants are they properly funded are
they hedging shouldn't it be a
requirement that all energy companies
have to buy what they're going to sell
the push for renewables makes economic
as well as environmental sense what's
good for the planet is also good for the
uk's energy resilience but when the wind
doesn't blow as has been the case at
times this summer fossil fuels are the
fallback that keep the lights on and as
long as that's the case the uk will be
vulnerable to global forces
greening energy supply will take a
generation this crisis needs a solution
in days not years
paul kelso sky news in gloucestershire